Hi, everyone.
I'm about to show you some presentation of
new concepts and we have a lot of code.
So, please bear with me.
I hope we're going to have fun in the next
25 minutes and hopefully learn one or two
tricks.
But before we start, I'm whenever I'm going
to show you what's under construction right
now, the main thing here is to put the language
that will show the kind of amazing features
that may or may not come to JavaScript and
all the problems that a new feature can bring
to ship those features to ourselves.
That said, I'm going to bring you back to
the future.
[theme song from Back to the Future playing]
So, I would like to start my presentation
with a tricky question.
What is this?
So, this has different meanings than this
in other language where it most likely refers
to the code scope.
So, in the scope, this in JavaScript, it's
the object.
So, not browser, it's window.
And the web itself, NodeJS, model.exports
and so on.
But what about this inside a function?
Well, depends.
It depends how this function is called.
I will show you my components.
It's a very simple class that has just one
premier and one method.
So, if you're looking at this line 15 here,
you will see that whenever I click on the
button, I want to console log, property.
But actually, my intention is to hit the button
element.
But this the context here is the button event.
I will create it because the button element
doesn't have the full property.
So, how to make this predictable?
So, this inside of JavaScript is tricky.
We can just buy into things.
The first is the prototype.bind which binds
the context of the first sent to the bind
function to the method you want to call.
And error function.
So, I will show the previous example with
these two techniques.
The first one you can see here, this bottom
line here, it's basically binding the cat
instance into meow method.
So, I will print out this one.
I will print out button element there.
And then with error function, it's here.
But you will see that I don't need to explicitly
bind this because it takes the lexical this
and then we will have button console property.
So, the thing is, error function removes a
lot of complexity in order to predict that
this is in a function.
But we still have two cases that we need to
explicitly bind this on a function.
The first one is this one.
Whenever we present in the language here,
you will see that I have a new object called
Obj.
But I don't extend this from the object prototype.
I don't have has own property.
So, when I want to check if I have the X property
inside the Obj, calling property, and the
prototype.
So, to fix this, I need to extract this function
from the object prototype and then call this
in the first context.
In the second, the first for the function.
It's kind of tricky.
In the second one, whenever I want to extract
a method from an object, I need to explicitly
call the context.
So, how do you call this case in a more natural
way?
This is the route for our first proposal.
ｶ?ｶ
this comes with two syntaxes.
The uniform and binary form.
The binary form takes whatever we have on
the left side as a context, it binds to the
right side of the operator.
So, that example could be rewritten on the
lines five and ten?
Yeah?
The last one?
Like this one.
So, it works.
And we need to shift, of course.
And the operator is a little bit different.
It takes the base of the reference you are
passing and sets it as the context of the
methods.
So, this could be the cat.meow.bind and inside.
This we can call because we can compose personalities
through methods.
You can extract those methods and compose
them like in this internal library.
Or on this implementation, our XGS5, there's
a way to do this here.
I don't know if they still encourage this.
I won't do it.
But it's an example.
For example, on this J query library, you
can extract the functions you need.
And it's nice because you bundle only the
functions you need.
And plus, it makes it easy to extend those
libraries.
It's a good solution for the methods, but
it relies on this to be bound.
How can we compose the functions in the same
way without relying on this?
So, let's suppose I have this function here.
This functionality.
Whenever the user puts something, I need to
sanitize this and textualize all the digits
I receive and then log those.
So, usually this is a way that we can do this.
But to make it readable, we end up having
a lot of intermediary variables.
And I think someone can say, ah, this could
be written without using this variable.
But it will look more or less like this.
It could be tricky because we may have a lot
of nested functions, one inside the other
like this.
So, to solve this problem, I wanted to present
you to you the second proposal.
ｶ?ｶ
part operator.
It's a syntax for function composition.
It creates a chain of functions and it's backwards
compatible.
So, remember this example here?
Using pipeline operator, I can rewrite this
one with this code example.
So, you can see on the top of the pipeline
chain you have the subject.
And then you start to pass this object through
the next one, and the result will be the subject
for the following stack and so on and so forth.
And this code could be to this.
It will remain.
You don't need to write all those variables.
What if that textualized number needs to receive
a second parameter?
For example, if we have a need to only textualize
zeros and ones, how can we do that here?
One possible solution is to create a narrow
function to receive a one per meter.
And inside this function, bind the second
parameter inside of this.
But it creates a syntax server because you
need to wrap to need to wrap the error
function with the parentheses.
So, it's kind of tricky.
And what if I need to process the sanitized
and what if the sanitized function needs to
process the server?
I can await this.
But it's tricky because this line here, it's
not clear how this would go to.
I can get this to the rate, parameter call
with the step.
Or I wait for the sanitize and then the result
will be a function that then I will send parameter.
So, we have a tricky question.
A tricky it's tricky to reason about how
which one of those could be the two.
To answer this question, we need to understand
the two proposals we have for this.
Because they're proposals don't cover this
completely.
So, I want to present you the first one, which
is smart line.
You have this in two ways.
You can see here we have line two, the top
style, and the line four, the bear style.
Whenever we need to use parentheses or describe
brackets, you need to use the top, and then
you need to use the hash token to as a
place holder for the subject for the previous
step.
From the previous step.
And whenever I do anything, it's straightforward.
You just need to do use it.
This is information that in this chart it
is subject to change.
It's not final.
What are carry?
If you try to use it in the first, since you
are using parentheses, it thinks that it's
topic style since you don't have the token
for the syntax server.
So, the good way to do this is on the second
example here.
This is good because
>> There's a new challenger!
WILLIAN: We have a new challenger.
So, there is the F# pipeline proposals.
The data proposal.
It just extends the minimal proposal with
an await step.
And it you can see on this example here,
you have just a solo await step here.
And this means that it needs to await for
the first step to be finished.
And then as soon as that previous step is
finished, then it passes to the next step.
You can see here that we still have the error
function being wrappered with the parentheses.
But these are I will show you how we can
solve this just in a couple minutes.
We will discuss the operator.
We saw this example here with the sharp as
a token.
We can do this.
We can solve this this line with partial
application.
But first I need to explain to you what is
partial application?
Partial application refers to a process of
giving a function without any editing.
It returns another function with a smaller
entity.
By bounding the fixed parameters.
And by the way, it's the number of the programmers
that a specific function takes.
So, I have this example here where a function.
And then you receive it, and the name and
location.
Just console log those.
But what if this example like this is just
straightforward, but what if we need to fetch
the location for the server?
I don't know why.
But then we will end up with this kind of
code that we have some parameters like that
we assigned before.
And then whenever we have this chain reserved,
we console log it.
Or call the function.
This kind but we still have a way to bind
this and create a partial application in ECMAScript.
So, we can do this using function bind.
Sometimes we forgot that binds bind
dot on binds the concept, but also binds parameters.
So, if the first parameter is the but the
second parameter is what you want to call.
And it returns a new function just with the
remaining missing parameters.
So, with this, I can rewrite that function
using this bind.
So, on the first line you can see that this
is achievable.
But what if I want to bind just the first
and the last parameter?
There is a problem with the binder because
I'm sorry the bind function.
It takes the parameters from the left to right
without jumping in one of those.
So, this is a problem.
And someone can say, yeah, but we can solve
this with carry.
Yes, we can.
But you need to remain that even though carry,
it's our way to achieve a partial application,
doesn't mean that carry is partial application.
Carry is, each time you carry a function,
you receive another function and add and minus
one.
And so, that example, let's say I want to
just bind the first and the last parameter
so I can write the three first lines of code.
Create like that carry function that has the
location.
Then on the line five I bind the first two
parameters and then I receive the function
to bind to call with the third one online
eight.
So, you can see that it's kind of a purpose.
Because whenever we want to change the configuration
that you want to bind, you need to rewrite
that carry function there.
And, yes, of course, you can do this with
a partial application with an error function.
Which it's kind of better than the carry function.
But you still need to write the function for
each configuration of parameters.
So, this is the hook for our last proposal
for today.
ｶ?ｶ
partial application.
Partial application proposal creates two new
tokens to be placed in this the parameters.
So, the question mark is for and the ellipses
is for multiple.
So, the examples could be written in this
way.
The first and second parameters being bound.
And the third one, a question mark.
This will return a new function that you can
call later with the missing parameters.
It's nice because you can do a lot of different
configurations of parameters without them
having to do any kind of code.
But, wait.
There is more.
There is this.
This token.
And it's it spreads the unbalanced parameters
on a specific position.
It's very useful whenever you want to bind
like the first parameters and you don't need
to care about the rest of those or the last
one.
So, I have an example here.
For example, this is a function that it's
much greater than zero.
So, I receive a bunch of numbers and I need
to return whenever I have a number greater
than zero, I return the max of those.
Whenever I only received negative numbers,
I return zero.
So, this one, it's okay.
But we can do better.
With this we can bind just the zero as the
first parameter and don't care about the rest.
And this will return a function with zero
being bound.
And this is nice because it doesn't matter
how I can call it, if I call in the first
configuration it will return the same as before.
And since zero is bound to math.next, I will
receive zero whenever it sends just negative
numbers.
[ Laughter ]
So, I have at least you have this configuration
on the F# proposal.
And I told you that this kind of syntax over
here to wrap an error function with this balance.
But with partial application we can rewrite
this line four to this.
And we have more like pre code, a readable
one.
So, then you may ask me, should I use this
all of this amazing stuff in production?
No.
These proposals are in the very early stage.
nothing I showed you is even in the stage
two.
The binary is just stage zero and the other
two in stage one.
That is a lot of conversations to be done
in order to fix that syntax.
One form of one proposal may shape the syntax
of the other or even remove completely.
So, my point here is to call you to participate
with this discussion.
On my second slide I will share with you later
on, there is the link for TC39 proposals page.
Whenever you wanted to like show your interest
in some proposals or express your concerns,
open an issue, put stars, create a talk about
it, as I did.
Before I finish, I want to thank that guy,
Brendan Bush who was the guy who helped me
finish with these designs.
Because as a JavaScript designer.
This guy here, Daniel.
Suddenly he is behind me.
He helped me with the technical stuff.
Like don't introduce any misconceptions to
you.
These are my contacts if you want to get in
touch with me.
I will try to in the next weeks write all
of these in an act code that may help you
to understand more about it.
And with this, I think I will leave you.
[ Applause ]